die herren der einzigartige der extrem
charmant und unglaublich gut auf die
elefanten
wir haben auch neuen status viele funde
als bier ein werkzeugkoffer und unser
aussehen ja habt ihr schon gesehen dass
ich auch ein bisschen verändern
unfassbar viele von euch haben ihn
geschrieben dass ich mal wieder movistar
planet hochladen soll von daher würde
ich sagen bewegen wir uns direkt ins
café und schauen erstmal ob sich die
leute noch an uns
a
irgendwie schreibt keiner was luca ok
thomas 15 hat luca geschrieben darauf
würde ich sagen antwort manchmal ganz
freundlich was willst du diese leute ja
er hat den raum verlassen
ja die leute lieben mich hier ja und
mein gott okay die nächste person hat
luca geschrieben
dein girl 123 schreibt das darauf
antworten da einfach mal lasst mich in
ruhe
ja das ist das was die leute an elephant
aa so lieben
höflichkeit möglichkeit kartoffel ist es
luca er glaubt schon eure wii session
sehen aus wie kartoffeln man sprachen
lernen da regnet wenn ich dich feier
schreibt sie sie schreibt also keine
ahnung was ihr im café abgeht das
verlässt mich jetzt erstmal wir gehen an
den strand das team um und so
nur wenige minuten später
ja
ist ja wie wir vielleicht gerade am
strand sein
dann verlassen wir den strand mal wieder
und jenes einkaufszentrum war dafür der
erste level 18 ich bin allerdings level
23 weil ich bin ja schon ein erfahrener
profis auch alles leer
nicht nur elefanten sind gerade ein paar
leute hier reingekommen von daher
stellen wir uns mal neben angel und
schreiben einfach mal so ein flirt
anfangen du bist so süß wenn ich dich
anschauen bekomme ich diabetes
ja also wendet sich direkt mit mir ins
bett steiger weise genau luca eine
person die sich denke was das für
komischer typ da schreibe ich jetzt mal
dass das duo das ist neue generation set
gibt es hier um teilten die musste einen
gegenstand von dem motto dieser woche
tragen okay also das gibt es ja öfters
beim riester planet dass man sich also
spezielle sage oh mein gott ich will
meinen tollen ja okay vielleicht könnte
ich wirklich etwas gebrauchen drei
wochen später drei feinde hinter sich
wir waren schotten und haben uns jetzt
so eingekleidet für den jetset raum und
dort befinden wir uns auch jetzt schon
meine lieben freunde das ist ein
bowlingcenter wir sind hier zusammen mit
funkel staub und einer person die gerade
abgehauen ist versuchen wir die funkel
stopp an zu flirten hast du ein navi
dabei ich suche den weg zu deinem herz
das wird mit ihr glaube ich nichts
heilig bin möbelpacker darf ich euch
beim ausziehen helfen
darauf eine antwort von den leuten im
raum da müssen die hardcore verzweifelt
sein
bisher hat noch niemand geantwortet
die dies zumindest nicht nur im raum
stehen also vielleicht schreibe ich die
noch mal direkt an kyra studiums perry
mal deine airports nicht aber die will
nur mehr airports man kann ich mit
airports irgendwie ein flotter spruch
raus hauen ich tausche main airports
gegen deine liebe kann nicht kennt und
ich weiß dass ich dahinter stehe
deswegen ist sie auch glaube ich so ein
bisschen so ein komischer typ aber ich
gebe nicht auf mit mein liebes an barem
ich bin vom adac darf ich dich heute
nacht abschleppen und bei dem sprochen
muss ich jetzt ein bisschen weiter
ausholen von daher habe ich einfach mal
hallo was ist euer beruf also einfach
mal so allgemein in die runde mit einem
oder gar nicht denkt dass ich sie direkt
ansprechen also was schauen was die
leute jetzt hier so schreiben auf die
frage ob hunger
ok danke für eure aussagekräftigen
antworten ich bin pilot von beruf du
hast textliche schuhe
[Musik]
ich bin pilot kira darf ich mal bei dir
genannten feldhockey rasch kannst du was
für dich behalten bestimmt bist du so
ein zehnjähriger eigentlich wollte ich
dir fragen ob sie mich für sich behalten
kann und zwar für immer
bei kira schluss luca ist lukas
[Musik]